>> Jesse: THERE'S NOTHING LIKE
THE GOOD OLD DAYS.
THAT MOMENT IN OUR LIVES WHERE
EVERYTHING WAS JUST RIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
MAYBE IT WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL WHEN
YOU WERE CAN'T OF THE FOOTBALL
TEAM OR IT COULD HAVE BEEN WHILE
YOUR KIDS WERE YOUNGER AND YOU
WERE JUST STARTING YOUR FAMILY.
LIFE WAS GOOD.
FOR OUR ECONOMY THOUGH, THE GOOD
OLD DAYS WERE JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO.
WHEN TRUMP WAS STILL PRESIDENT.
YOUR DOLLAR WENT A WHOLE LOT
FURTHER UNDER TRUMP.
YOU COULD FILL UP YOUR GAS TANK
FOR LESS THAN TWO BUCKS A GALLON
AND THE STOCK MARKET WAS DOING
SO WELL WE ALL LOOKED LIKE
GENIUSES.
>> THE 401(K)s, THEY ARE UP
90%.
95%.
[CHEERS]
>> I ALWAYS TELL THE STORY
PEOPLE COME UP TO ME THEY SAY I
WANT TO THANK YOU MY WIFE THINKS
I'M A TOTAL LOSER, SIR.
SHE THINKS I'M THE WORST PERSON
WITH MONEY, FINANCIALS.
SHE THINKS I'M JUST HORRIBLE AND
THE LAST THREE YEARS I'M UP 94%,
SIR.
SHE THINKS I'M A TOTAL GENIUS
WHEN IT COMES TO FINANCES.
>> Jesse: WELL IN BIDEN'S
AMERICA, WE'RE NOW ALL FOOLS.
NO LONGER GENIUSES.
BECAUSE I HATE TO SAY IT THE
GOOD OLD DAYS ARE OVER.
OUR ECONOMY HAS OFFICIALLY
REACHED BEAR MARKET TERRITORY
TODAY.
THE S&P FELL 20%.
THAT'S OFFICIALLY NOW
COLLAPSING.
NOW, ON TOP OF THAT, THE NASDAQ
IS OFF ABOUT 20 PERCENT THIS
YEAR AND THE DOW IS ABOUT 5,000
POINTS DOWN.
SINCE JANUARY.
THAT'S THE LONGEST LOSING STREAK
SINCE THE HEIGHT OF THE GREAT
DEPRESSION.
AND THERE IS NO SIGN THAT THIS
IS GOING TO SLOW DOWN EITHER.
WALL STREET SAYS THIS RECESSION
IS HERE AND THINGS ARE ABOUT TO
GET A LOT WORSE.
I CAN'T SUGAR COAT IT FOR YOU
GUYS.
OUR SAVINGS COULD BE ABOUT TO
GET WIPED OUT.
I MEAN, 401(K)s ARE ABOUT TO
GET SMASHED RIGHT NOW.
AND WE ARE GOING TO LOSE, AND WE
ARE GOING TO LOSE A LOT.
GAS PRICES ARE HITTING RECORD
HIGHS.
INFLATIONS ARE HITTING HIGHS.
COMPANIES ARE NOW FREEZING
HIRING, THAT MEANS LAYOFFS ARE
COMING.
BUT THIS DOESN'T SOUND IMPORTANT
TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT DOES?
>> NOTHING HAS CHANGED ON HOW WE
SEE THE STOCK MARKET.
WE DO NOT -- THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE KEEP AN EYE ON
EVERY DAY.
SO I'M NOT GOING TO COMMENT
ABOUT THAT FROM HERE.
>> Jesse: SCRANTON JOE MAY NOT
CARE ABOUT LAYOFFS OR YOUR
401(K)s GETTING ANNIHILATED.
MAYBE HE WILL REALIZE IT WHEN
ALL OF HIS WALL STREET BACKERS
STOP BAILING HIM OUT AND
DONATING TO HIM.
BUT, REMEMBER, HE IS NO MIND
READER.
SO NOW AMERICANS HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THIS LOOMING RECESSION
DURING THIS RIDICULOUS SUMMER
WE'RE ABOUT TO FACE.
AND ON TOP OF WORRYING ABOUT THE
WAR ON THE INSIDE OF OUR
COUNTRY.
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER IS ABOUT TO
SEE YOU A BIBLICAL FLOOD OF
MIGRANTS COMING THROUGH WHEN THE
HOT WEATHER HITS.
THIS IS MIGRATION SEASON.
WE'RE HEADING RIGHT INTO IT
RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE GEARING UP TO SEE MILLIONS
AND I MEAN MILLIONS OF ILLEGALS
POURING ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
TITLE 42 THANK GOOD MORNING IS
GOSH IS NO LONGERGOING TO BE PR.
WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW A JUDGE,
THANK GOSH, THAT'S PRESERVED IT
AND SO WE STILL HAVE THAT RIGHT
NOW AS A WEAPON.
THAT'S JUST A BAND-AID.
THAT REALLY ISN'T GOING TO STOP
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON.
AND RIGHT NOW JOE BIDEN IS OUT
OF THE COUNTRY.
HE'S IN SOUTH KOREA RIGHT NOW HE
IS NOT MAKING AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN, IS HE TRYING TO MAKE
SOUTH KOREA GREAT AGAIN.
HE IS TOURING A CHIP FACTORY IN
SOUTH KOREA, MIXING UP THE NAMES
OF THE PRIME MINISTER OVER
THERE.
IS HE TRYING TO PIVOT TO ASIA.
WE NEED HIM TO PIVOT HERE TO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND WE NEED IT DONE QUICKLY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE TO TELL
YOU ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
BUT THE MAN IS SHOT.
HE IS NO LONGER CAPABLE OF
GOVERNING THIS COUNTRY.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
PAYING A VERY, VERY SEVERE PRICE
FOR IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE TO TELL
YOU TO DO.
IT'S GOING TO BE UP TO THE
COMMUNITIES, THE MAYORS, T